hopefully I'll get Landon slime No One
Is Safe you know what's up y'all we are
so excited to be hosting the 2023 Kids
Choice Awards I want to congratulate the
two of you such a big deal hosting the
2023 Kids Choice Awards first of all how
did this all even come together I mean
you know I've been a fan of the show for
many many years and I got the chance to
come these past two years and accept
Awards and then when they said would you
like to co-host I was like you're so
funny like that's a cute joke and then
they're like no no we mean it and I was
just so excited and then I found out you
were my co-host and it's just been
amazing since I found out we're so used
to you you know at the anchor desk
wearing a suit what has it been like to
really tap into something super fun like
this well I'm an 80s baby
um raised in the 90s influenced by the
2000s
so that means I've seen every era of
Nickelodeon I mean from the old school
shows like you can't do that on
television the double dare all the
Animated Series I also have an 18 year
old 16 and 12 year old at the house so
you know my family has grew up on
Nickelodeon and I've seen the Kids
Choice Awards so when they called me
there was Zero hesitation so this is an
absolute blessing and listen I love
sitting at the desk giving people what
they need on a daily basis giving you
the morning news right but we also need
this though you know just a night of fun
chaos we got some wild stuff happening
some big time surprises it's going down
all right
it at the 2023 Kids Choice Awards I want
to know changes surprises what tricks do
you have up your sleeve well I got to be
fresh because you know she's going to be
fresh you know what I'm saying things
are going to be how many wardrobe
changes
maybe a few there's going to be a few a
few three a few ten I mean I guess I'll
have to see when we get there but I know
I know there's gonna be some great looks
I'm excited okay so good fashion what
can you tease about the show okay so we
are making dreams come true and you know
people say that but like we're literally
making dreams come true so it's going to
be this blend between a live show but
also kids at home get to vote and adjust
the show in real time
um which is going to be amazing some
mind-blowing tricks magic stunts
um she's gonna be doing some stunts okay
maybe I shouldn't have said that but
stay tuned it's gonna be crazy and then
of course performances
yeah wait when you say stunts I mean
you've been crushing it on the Dancing
with the Stars tour obviously you took
home the Mirrorball trophy are you
dancing during the show or are you gonna
be like flying high through the air like
what are these stunts I mean you know my
my fear of heights definitely hold me
back but you know there's no fear coming
into the Kids Choice Awards you got to
be able to do it all got to leave it all
on the floor you know what I mean okay
so are you guys gonna be doing any
dancing on stage
yeah of course you know you've been
teaching NADA a move or two you know
after here we're gonna go straight to
the studio ballet class let's get ready
but but let's not forget all right I
used to score touchdowns in the NFL and
I would dance on my opponents you know
what I'm saying I'd be in there the
night before the game in the hotel full
choreography knowing when I score I'm
gonna shake my thing a little bit so
when I get on the stage I gotta do a
two-step with Charlie can I see a little
preview of this oh now see now you
asking for too much you know I mean and
I am warm up I'm 41 years old you're
gonna have me bust a hammy out here
who's gonna be here to support you guys
you're a father of three that's right is
your family gonna be here and again are
you the coolest dad in the world for
scoring this invite for the fam no doubt
my daughter's gonna be here she's 12
year old shout out to Mia Pearl
um my wife is going to be here but she
has to leave because my two boys are
playing in a championship game the same
day as the kca's is your fam gonna be
here is Landon gonna be here oh my
goodness I you know I'm very close
stuff to together they've came to every
show that I've been at and I'm excited
to see them here hopefully I'll get them
slimed hopefully I'll get Landon slime
No One Is Safe you know but they're all
going to be here so I'm excited how has
he been supporting you through this
whole Venture have you been like running
lines at home together and asking like
do you think this is this is funny like
do you guys do that type of stuff
um there's definitely a lot of talk I
show him you know everything that I'm
working on like at the end of the day
look what I did yeah so it's he's super
excited and and super supportive and you
know he does the same thing look what
I'm wearing to the show
oh yeah I love it if you have to tease
the kcas in three adjectives what is it
Big Time slime that's it
Big Time slime it's going down BB Rex is
performing we know Adam Sandler's
getting a big award what can you tease
about these big moments during the show
well Adam Sandler is a comedic genius so
um having him Grace the stage is going
to be incredible Bebe rexha and she's an
icon you know so she's going to hit the
stage and maybe even play with some
slime a little bit you know what I mean
we have this this very unique way of
testing how much slime we can create I
can't tell you any more than that but
it's going to be fun some of the biggest
celebrities are going to come out and
help us and then there's some really
really big names that are showing up
this year that I promise you I'm talking
about International type celebs I can't
say who they are but just stay tuned
foreign